we know the casting director that did
the uh Gran Torino that's about Hmong
people that was a whole group that
brought us out that was our first JK gig
wow so the monk Community has given a
lot of a lot of love to JK yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and we want to give it
back
[Music]
what
oh today's episode is going to be about
his son it's all about Hmong people
long people do we know about
h-m-o-n-g I'll be back you guys talk
okay
but I think he knows the most though I
think he died because he actually lived
in a Hmong Village in Thailand huh
their culture was almost eradicated
that's what I do know I actually don't
know very much who knows the least
because that'll be fun to tell them
about me dude so I think it's me bro my
only knowledge among people was the
movie Gran Torino uh that's I don't know
if that's the best source that's a great
film you know I just that's my only
reference among people I know during
like their new years they like to
[__] throw it down all the time oh
dude yeah there's always like these like
videos of like in like Stockton and
Modesto where they're just scrapping
everywhere
yeah in NorCal there's a huge diaspora
of them uh there was definitely like a
very large Hmong genocide with their
like entire culture was nearly
eradicated really yeah so let's start
with that let's start with how do we
know like Hmong people here in
California I only know because the twins
on kinjas are Hmong people can I just
stick up for the audience who maybe
doesn't know what the [__] among is for
a sec yes what's a monk that's the thing
yeah let's start there so long is
spelled
h-m-o-n-g and and from what I the very
little that I understand they're not
even like part they're not like uh Bound
by our country right like they there are
people that can be spread across
different Asian countries but originally
are they like they're like in indigenous
group in China right yes originally okay
this is what Hmong people have told me
is like in the movie Mulan the bad guys
that's their ancestors when they lost
the war they ran away to Southeast Asia
to hide out in the Hills because the
Chinese knew um the Emperor or whatever
was trying to genocide that oh okay that
is their history right I don't know what
the actual like ancestral accounts are
of them but but they are not of the
people of Southeast Asia so they are
undocumented
folks that live in the mountains of
Cambodia right Vietnam Thailand all that
yeah and in my I'm getting some pictures
here have you heard people speaking monk
yeah and what does it sound like because
it sound like closer to any of the other
Asian languages I don't know how to
describe it because I only hear it when
a villain an impact on the kids just get
drunk and then when they have to yell at
each other they speak in Hmong and
that's one like it's tight though yeah
so the Twins and kinjas are both hmong
and they're and they're B boys that are
from uh up north yeah from sac and in
Sac they got whole mung b-boy Crews and
they're dope
yeah they're dope they're just really
good they're just uh
yeah they're just like some of the top
Crews up there says among people are an
indigenous group in the East and
Southeast Asia in China among People are
classified as a subgroup of male people
the modern among reside mainly in
Southwest China uh and countries in
Southeast Asia such as Vietnam Laos
Thailand and Myanmar
so do you think you'd be able to tell
like who looks more Hmong than like
someone that's not
it just depends on what I'm comparing to
if you're like one of these people is
hmong and then the other person's like
Japanese yeah I can if you're the other
person's Korean yeah if the other person
you know what I mean but if it's just
generic southeast Asia and you don't
tell me one of them is Hmong I'm gonna
guess one of the other Southeast Asians
by by population density yeah yeah yeah
I know they got common last names like
you know how Vietnamese has to win they
have like I think it's like Vang or like
song or like or like there's like common
ones they got like cha I think that's
one but um I didn't know any Hmong
people in the states it later on in Life
After College when we started traveling
for JK and they were booking Us in
different areas because they don't live
in most of them they don't live in major
cities okay most the Hmong people they
live in like farm towns in the country
like Fresno I know there's a huge
population out in Minneapolis I know
there's one out like in Detroit
um Michigan
um out out in the South uh and I don't
know why but I read up a little bit and
so during the Vietnam war
um Hmong people actually helped the U.S
government because they're like they
lived out in the hills and they were
also I guess getting discriminated
against by the Viet Cong so the Hmong
folks worked with are like Rangers our
army rangers and helped us find
um Pathways to attack the Vietcong
another one is I think during the
Cambodian genocide they were targeted
uh from Pol Pot screw so there's a with
that Refugee of Vietnamese and and
cambodians or whatever Hmong groups came
along with because they were on the side
of the U.S soldiers and with that I
think
they were dispersed around the U.S but I
didn't know they were in like California
until way later on where I'm like oh
there's a huge community in Fresno yeah
what do you know about them Ryan
um the only thing I ever knew was uh was
that they were very similar to another
group I remembered I I before I knew
anyone that was Mom I knew somebody that
was Cham what is that it's like um it's
like the Vietnamese version of mom where
like they are an indigenous group that
was you know uh in some way persecuted
so they had to spread out and they ended
up in like all different parts of the
world and uh I remembered that there was
this girl that I had met with Chum and
um she was like beautiful but then her
friends are like don't even try she's
Chapman I was like the what why what is
that oh it's just a stick to her own
stick to her yeah because there's so few
of them that she has to marry another
guy who's charm whoa she was dope and
then after that when I had learned uh
Hmong I always like most people will
mistake it for Mongolian yeah because
they'll just hear it and go oh Mom oh
it's Mongolian I think it's like an
abbreviation and then someone was
telling me like uh oh yo you ever seen
the Mong B boys and I was like Mong B
boys and then that's when uh we learned
about air steps and like these all like
Hmong b-boy Crews up North and then
someone was like yeah they're like the
uh they said they're like the indigenous
Asians of like Asia I was like oh that's
interesting and then that's when I
learned it was very similar to Chan I
remember hearing what Korean was with
for the first time
and I was like man you just making [__]
up trying to be special because in my
little like I was like there's only
Chinese and Japanese and all the Korean
just [__] making [__] up and then I
remember hearing mung again I'm like man
there's only Korean Chinese
you're just making up manga be special
and then I found out they're like a real
thing
I was pretty good
you can also here at like an earlier
time too that like Hmong dudes were like
tough like there were like a lot of mung
gangs like very similar to like Long
Beach and like some more yeah yeah yeah
they were very like uh you know because
they're they're uh you know when you
when you get spread out from another
country the same way that a lot of the
Vietnamese immigrants were in some towns
like you end up having to be very
protective of yourselves and yeah
everyone's [__] with you you live in
a low-income neighborhood you know and
and a lot of them ended up being like
what you said like you've seen Gran
Torino yeah and you know that that's my
only that's the first time I heard about
Hmong people because I even asked
villain like Bill from his crew back in
the day I'm like yo if you didn't start
dancing would you have like your life
would have been very different on he's
like yeah it wouldn't have been it
probably would have been a lot more
difficult
so none of us knows much about the monks
none of us we have we have hella uh
Hmong fans though yeah because after
um you know we started getting
called to these different schools and
stuff like remember when me you and
David did that show out in Minneapolis I
think yeah or yeah Minnesota right yeah
yeah it is Minneapolis that whole group
was a mom Club those 300 something kids
that came out wow there was only a
handful of like Chinese kids but that
that was the Hmong Community out there
yeah and then
um I know about them because the church
we went to
we they had a they had a whole
connection with Thailand and they were
um they sponsored like this like this
aids clinic where it was a a lot of
um
girls that were sold into trafficking
and then when they were caught with STDs
and AIDS and stuff like that their
brothels would just throw them away oh
and then so our church had like this uh
like it was like a program yeah it was
like they lived there it was Christian
all this stuff okay yeah yeah and you
know how those SDA communities really
deep into Health right yeah so everyone
becomes doctors and so there was like a
medical thing to to give and then they
taught us about where these girls come
from so it was like a whole thing we're
gonna go build churches in their
Community yeah and then so we went from
Bangkok all the way to the border of
Burma into a Hmong Village and these are
the photos you lived in the Hmong
Village we lived in the Hmong Village
with Hmong people and you just could
look at it yeah
and then I'll I'll take these pictures
and and show them um you guys could do a
slideshow oh my hey Eddie what the Yeah
so I mean we were part of the church
freaking guy I don't know they sponsored
the trip so we went out there to bring
like money you guys will see him I'm
sure super down the screen but yeah that
was the that was the story of Uncle
drugs he was a heroin addict or
opiumatic he lived in the back of the
pastor's house
and uh the way they made money was they
had a they had an opium dude [__]
joke and and they were teaching us like
this is the only way these guys can make
money there's no there's no school so
that's why uh our church was building a
church and building buildings for them
to get educated
and then um running water that they just
built a well recently yeah and then so
we lived in there every single day and
then they're like this is how they live
how do you rate the Hmong seesaws are
they pretty good pretty efficient these
little kids were monkeys all of them are
Mom kids kids are so cute they're
[__] cute Bro Look at Joan
these pictures of Joe are all and then
so what they were teaching us is that
like the way they find these girls is
recruiters will come into these Villages
and be like they know they're poor so
they'll be like hey uh is your son or
daughter looking for work and then they
would basically get their daughters and
say we could take them to the city yeah
and then they can work do they know what
that means no they pull a Switcheroo on
them these dude these villagers are
[__] so sweet they have no idea and
the thing is
um there's there's there's child
soldiers from the Burmese border and um
a militia group like a terrorist group
from Burma heard that there was a
missionary group and they came into the
village and there were guys my age at
that time yeah
13 14 with just massive guns that were
bigger than them strapped to their arms
like in the back of pickup so they came
in the village leader and the pastor
they all got together and then they came
with the agreement but during that time
they told all of us to just stay in the
house and wait so we're just like
peeking out and I was like this is
[__] nuts
and then after that
um
you know it was it was just a wild
experience right because like you don't
know what is what is really like
happening what's good what's bad but
they told us about the economy there is
the only way that these guys can make
money in these Villages is because
they're not documented citizens of
Thailand uh they're basically these drug
traffickers come and say build these
opium fields and then and then when it's
harvest time they just sell it to them
these guys don't know he they think
they're growing papaya like they don't
know and then one of the guys we call
them Uncle drugs but he just smoked
opium every [__] day
damn yeah and and he I'm in a photo with
them he's that dark dude like that's
awful drugs yeah Uncle drugs and then
their their religion is witchcraft like
they do a lot of Ceremonies and things
like that and I guess like the church
was trying to help them educate build an
economy
have some type of stability so they can
remove their dependency on drugs and
selling off their daughters wow because
the daughters they would say like they
don't know that that's what's happening
what they what they're told by these
recruiters is yeah you can go because
this does happen where where they're
like hey uh I'ma send my kid to the city
they're gonna get educated they're gonna
go to school or they're gonna go work
and then bring money back to the Village
right it happens all the time but then
these con artists will bring the girls
and then the girls will never come back
because they'll be like all drugged up
and ashamed of what they're doing so
then when we heard that [__] they're
like dude this is some crazy [__] they
didn't insulate us like even though we
were church kids they're like this is
the [__] reality wow they just gave
it to you straight yeah dude they gave
us they told us everything we met all
the it's
it started with this I think I forgot
I'm kind of confused of the timeline I
was 14 but it's I remember we saw the
whole process of where these girls come
from and where they ended up and we met
them face to face it was sad as [__]
yeah like factory farming like you saw
the cow being slaughtered
huh like you saw you you said you saw
the whole process you saw the end part
where the chicks are getting taken to
hotels and [__] oh well that's rampant
in Thailand there's like sex tourism
just you see miners holding hands with
adults walking around like old old guys
it's normal yeah it's out in the public
yeah but and then that's funny because
the way they have their taxis they have
these back of the pickup trucks with
rails and then and then these these
seats in the back yeah so we would yeah
we would be there so me and my buddy
Eddie we would hang on the bars and
every time we saw a guy with a hooker we
would just be like this the whole time
[__] you [__] you [__] you you know
they're missionaries
we're just on the we're just a truck we
know this story we're all mad right so
every every guy we see that's like 50
years old with the four Justice holding
hands [__] you I'm Christian [__] we're
like spitting at them we're just like
[__] you
[__] you we only eat fish Latter-Day
Saints [__] you yeah
literally and we're all smoking
cigarettes too because out there you
could be like 18. I mean you don't have
to be 18 to buy cigarettes so we're just
out there like [__] smoking
cigarettes like flicking at them
spitting at people [__] you [__] you and
then we're going there building churches
how many years after that did you [__] a
hooker
oh man wait it just probably was you
know me what's the timeline by the way
it was in America I know
probably like in my 20s you just know
he's 14 years old so the [__] you became
you're the fuckey you're the guy getting
[__] me [__] me [__] me that's what it
came from yeah yeah it was it was fun
for me um as long as you've known
villain in Impact like did you have did
they ever mention anything that they
have to do that's different because
their mom
um
I can't believe you know people named
building an impact and they're not on
American Gladiators
[Laughter]
b-boy name they're among
names
like fuses
I know that they have
I think it's either their sister or
their cousin that's like a shaman whoa
sick yeah so like uh that means that
there are times where they'll say like
this is a funny thing because uh during
the pandemic I was like starting to go
fishing a lot more but hey let's go
fishing they're like oh we can't go
fishing during this time but why can't
you go fishing during times because all
of my sisters are Shaman and uh uh she
saw an omen that uh yeah for like three
years or whatever nobody in our family
can go fishing because if you do
something bad's gonna happen to you and
something bad did happen to like their
uncle or something who actually went
fishing during that time and didn't heed
the warning wow
three years is also a giant window it's
a huge win though and the next thousand
days a lot Anything Could Happen yeah
like he probably [__] a hooker and
just got AIDS or something and then died
at the fishing hole yeah and like it's
probably fishing what they during that
period they did official and they love
fishing the second that period finished
they [__] went fishing like crazy and
then he got hurt we get a lot of
messages for some reason I've noticed
about people asking like when are you
gonna get like among dude on the show I
don't know no among dude I don't know I
only know them yeah okay same I know guy
but he's he's all uh in the east coast
they're very rare that's why like
they're not saying that's a deep cut
like most people wouldn't even really
know what that is in L.A it's hard yeah
I remember it's a deep cut I've heard of
it before but I didn't know what it was
yeah it's like part of uh it's very rare
that you would anyone would kind of like
really know yeah I don't even think I
met my first Hmong person until it was
maybe college or out of state or
something oh yeah okay you know Cedric
he brought us out he's he's in his
community the we know the casting
director that did the uh Gran Torino
that's about Hmong people yeah so so
yeah that that was a whole group that
brought us out that was our first JK gig
wow and it was a it was a it was a mock
producer yeah so the monk Community has
given a lot of a lot of love to JK yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and we want to give
it back we love that you guys [__] chain
we love it
let's go
foreign